immigration and Homeland Security
officials are still assessing what
impact the end of title 42 is having on
the U.S Mexico border government
officials say there has not been a surge
of migrants since the policy ended a
little more than 24 hours ago but
migrant rival numbers remain high Nicole
skanga is in southern Texas with the
story of some of those feeling or
fleeing rather violence and persecution
who are now at the border
these are the lucky ones Jonathan Gomez
trekked across six countries hiking his
way through the perilous land bridge
connecting Panama and Colombia the
Darien Gap carrying with him the memory
of his child and girlfriend left at home
in his native Venezuela
the 20 year olds who paid 350 dollars to
Colombian cartel members showed us in
cell phone video the perilous River he
had to cross
we met Gomez at this Brownsville Texas
Gas Station where migrants have been
washing cars for days to raise enough
money to Charter a bus to San Antonio
it's on the same street he sleeps and
where we ran into him collecting
blankets from Aid workers also there
Jose Moreno from Venezuela who told us
he surrendered his entire savings eight
hundred dollars to Guatemalan police
enroute to the U.S
at the border agents divide men and
women for processing separating Moreno
and his his pregnant wife he started
checking shelters for her by night and
washing cars by day even on his 21st
birthday
then this happened abandoning their
sponges and Rags for a moment the
migrants broke out into a familiar round
of happy birthday
foreign now in the U.S a moment of joy
and celebration after a long journey a
fleeting chance at Asylum no longer
afforded to most
we've since heard from Jose Moreno who
tells us he was able to make brief
contact with his wife U.S border
authorities moved her to Phoenix for
processing part it part of a
decompression effort in this overcrowded
region of the Border they are still
searching for a way to reunite Dana
all right Nicole from Brownsville Texas
thank you
they were hunted nearly to Extinction
but now